ああああ
ああ
a 僕は
お茶筒を作る職人として6代目として
ずっと今職人をしています
お茶筒っていうのは明治の頃からこういう
ものをずっと作り続けるところなんです
けれども
でお茶筒を作りながらやり続け
お茶筒っていうのはまあ作るだけではなく
てお客さんが交通と使っていくんです
けれども
ちょうどこれは100年以上
使い込んだ方
この100年以上たったをシャツっていう
のは
実は今作ってもうと全く一緒のもので
漫画行きこれが壊れたとしても
ハウスを交換しながら
またもう100年使っていただけるよう
なので基本的に毎日考えていることという
のは今
をして
買っていただいた方が
100年先祝儀を持ってこられた時に
の周囲ができる
そのためにはどうすればいいのかという
ことをずっと考えながら
参り気を消灯しています
でも実際
os の第1期
大変な時代があって
親父は僕には共通となっています
なので大学のときまーとーつなんて言われ
てパレ社会人として終わりの先輩の
ということを聞きながらは者
他所で働くかと思って要素で3年くらい
働いていたんですけれどもその時に家の
無茶ですが海外の方が変わっていかれたと
いうことがある
そこからもしかしたらうちのおちゃつ海外
でも売れるんじゃないかそしたらを入れる
ように日本の中でダメになるかもしれない
けれども世界中ということを考えたら
いけるんじゃないかと思って日本の
マーケットだけでは世界中のマーケットを
考えていこうということで入りできます
で毎時
これ世界売りたいんだっていうことを言っ
たらもう一羽
青かっ
外国のそう分かるわけじゃない
そんな事を指し言われたのをすごく覚えて
います
でもやるならまあ仕方ないであったらいい
よということで
いいえもどって来るわけですでもその時に
親父に言われたの場
お前に教えない
見て覚える
教えるもうちょっとひどけ
なので朝から晩まで多いですねつの g
飛びながら有効で行っている違う
よかったないぐらいの数とか
2のずっとやりながら毎日公団などを覚え
ていくんです
やっぱりそういう風にして
なんでその時は美味しいを教えてくんない
だろう他の花職人に教えるなんて僕には
教えないんだ
すごく悩んだりもしたこと今でも覚えてい
ます
でも今もうとを損ねちゃんと理由はかじゃ
ないか
教えられるとやっぱり表面的なことを覚え
てそれだけで待って欲しいでしょ
でも見て覚えるだと本当に僕たちは覚え
ないといけないことを自分で何だ自分の
一報として覚えていくということ大役を
やらせたかったんじゃかなと言いはた思う
ようになります
私はかいますけれどもここはこれぞれた
多い上位4欲しかったのでおじいちゃんと
過ごすことが多かったです
おじいちゃんは
後高校
踏水会といっしょイヤァオ
大変なく家で作れるわけな施設を
毎日ムスッああああ泳いで泳いで泳いで
走って帰ってまたを入れてみてそんな
hulu
をシンプルにすべててくれるんです終わっ
たらもうクタクタになっていててその時に
おじいちゃんが
敬老乗車券でません帰るかそれとも
タクシーで帰ったと
タクシーやからそうと感じたらから関係の
敬老乗車券だ誰だから
早速言うかという
そのことが欲しいちゃいするとクイン
いってその特にもやっぱり買ってもらって
もいいただ半分ずつしながら
さて一応まだロージーちゃんちょっとつ
楽しいことをやっぱり取り込んでくれたん
です
そうやっているうちにおじいちゃんの感覚
ってようなちゃんと自分の中に入ってきて
猛暑したが今
コーヒーの缶を作ったり
タイセールっていうのはそういう楽しい5
文型のおじいだろうそう
実際そうやって来ずーっと毎日
ものづくりをしながら
どうやって次の外につないでいくのかなっ
ていうふうに思ったときにボクは常に
背中にやっぱりそうやって一緒にいたお
じいちゃんのことや護衛子がやってきた
ことということを感じながら自分も子供が
いるので子供の子
コーヒー茶のこと金具ジャン僕の魔法ほ
どっていうことを考えながら今どうすべき
なのかということをずっと
考えるようになります
なので
やっぱりその自分自身としてのもう作りで
はないとふうに職人がもの作っていうのは
そういう風に感じるんです
読者かというと
あり私自身の愛ではなくて
うぇい
我々は私たち休みっていうようなそういう
感覚を持っています
それこそ大事な行ってきている家であれば
おじいちゃーん
ひいおじいちゃんオヤジそれを背中に感じ
ながら
孫のことを考えてやって来そういう意味で
の wii でもあるし
逆にら回これは道具なので
僕たちは作るけれども常に使っていただく
かたことを考え
そういう意味でもあると思っています
というのは実をおじいちゃんの頃ピンは
このお茶筒の開け閉めの
この柔らかさというのはもっともっと
硬かったです
何故かという
今この後茶筒を今の人に私を抱い結構要望
から来たんですよ総数から開かないんです
でもおじいちゃんの子の応援した頃もそう
ですけれども
家族だけ表はきちんとアフっていうことは
わかっているんです
ここを持てば革新を開いているでも横から
もスト図っ
ここを押すと開け閉めしやすい
だから宇治茶のからもっとわかってる
わかったんです
でも今の時代というのは
を早く持つと
開かないけれどもそうやっての人が多いの
でそういう人のためにもう少し方向言う
なので見た目が全く一緒なんですけれども
今の人たちに合わせ今でものを作りをして
いくわけなんです
その中で
やっぱり自分自身ではなくて使うかターン
そういうことを考えながら愛ではなくて
みんなもの救い
でもいわゆるそのういって言っても
individual な安易の集合体で
はなくて
何が同じ感覚を持っている依存な感覚を
持ちながら物作りをしているのか職人じゃ
ないかな
でもおじいちゃんのがやってきたこと
親父の代に行ってき
僕の買いに行ってきたことっていうのは
からそれぞれ特色があって
やはりその時代に合わせ問題自分自身やり
たいことっていうのはそこに織り込んで
くるわけなんです
なのでそうし
ありが織り込まれてるんじゃないかなと
思っています
なのでなんとなくなんですけれども
もちろん w と音6時の良いがあって
そのちょうど中間にこの子の愛はあるよう
がそんな感覚を僕たちは持っていますそう
いう意味でのもいいです
でもー
じゃあ告げない渡そうとしたと
いくらこの文字の範囲が
しても
それが邪魔になるというふうに思ってい
ますなので強だね私時はこの工事の範囲を
w パピーの中に溶け込ましてそして次の
内部を出すっていうことが必要なんじゃ
ないか
この報じ周りを作るのにすごく拡大拡大
登録するわけなんですもうそれを溶け込ま
し
その時この者ウィルいいお
何かこう県境のようなもので見ると中でを
じっちゃの間ずっと詰まっている
そういうもの救いを職人意見はずとしてき
たのではないか
ます何で
唯一無二のものスクール s は鉄道
それはそれ素晴らしいなと思うでも同じ
くらい
あって続いて帰宅ということも何か価値の
ある
そんなものすごいということになっている
のではないかなと
いう風に
共同
こうやって酒を
oh ちゃんがいと僕の代でここに柔らか
さが違うというお話をし
文
スクールもう厚底140万円はしごの
ちょっと作り続けてるんですけれども
同じものを創り続けるためには全く同じ
ものをかけを作り続けることではやっぱり
続いていかないんです
私じゃ順序従っていくそれを何か上で抗
釣り上げるようなそんなものが必要だっ
たりする
それが今ではコーヒーの間でやってあり
ます関係あったり壁をすることであったり
また本超えた節目の感覚を少し変えること
であったりということで
140万よくを
なんとなく
はたから見ると海可能というのはすぐ
すごくコンサバティブで味もとずっとやっ
てるっていう風に見えてるんですけど実は
力って見ていただいてよく見ていただくと
その後茶筒の一本線がつを過去から未来に
続いているんですけれども
その横を反復用トイレの中
エコー右に行ったりていて
振動しているようなそんな風な感覚をふっ
かちゃん思っています
いうとちょっと1個身を引いて傍から見る
とその反復
鼓動家は一般の選手が見えないそんな風に
映っているかもしれないですけれども
実はすごく高速で高振動しているような
そんな感覚を持ってい
親父はよく言います
相変わらずやるの凄い難しい
京都でそこで相変わらず犯しそうである
ようないうところほど実はそういった
ルールをみなさんやってこられたのかも
しれないです
長蔵
2000年に戻ってきて今でちょっと22
年このをしようとしているんですけれども
今
日本の職人のことを色々と白
その中で
ついた分かったということは
職人がか動いている
やはりその3地無しそして会おう
すごく少ないなあっていうことに気付け
ます
準備している
室の数で年間総生産数を破って行くと一人
当たり150万円分ぐらいなんですよ
ということは人が働いている
お金その職人橋貼られてを変えてすごくす
なぁ
でも
今の若い子たちは結構この世界に入ってき
たらいいしていただいているんですけど
なんねーそういった魅力があるんだろうな
というふうにすごく考え
あるシリアの職人さんが言うんです
僕は調べたところによると
家を書いている人といを見ている人と幸せ
もと数が絵を書いていく所が高い
そんなことを聞いた時にもしかしたら僕達
っていうのは単なるとかねっていうのでは
なくて心の中に
入ってくるお金に替わるものが6
昔で言うと6っていう言葉なのかもしれ
ないですけど
そういう方っていうのは僕たちの中には
あるんじゃないかな
そういうものが実際ちょっと溜まっていく
からこそ
こういうお仕事ということが
本当に気持ちよく
やってられる毎日があるんでは
考えると思う
やっぱりその中で
これから詐欺っていうことを考えた2
今の日本を含めて世界というのはそういう
お金 a
時間
そういうことで動いているって
をそこが大事なのすごくよくを張っている
んですけれども
それだけでもないんじゃないかなと言う
なんかそのおじいちゃんとー
僕が繋がってた心のつながりであったり
もしかしたら今 os と家の子供が一緒
に何か工房でものを作り出したり
けれども
そういうことを見る校
おかげではない何かところのつながりって
言う
これから先の世の中を考えた時に送付
大事だと思うなっている
お金
時間
特に時間なんかは今の物理学者は人間が
考えたのが時間があって存在しないって
いう
お金もそうかもしれません人が考えたのっ
世界中の感覚を統一するために
考え出した持っていうことかもしれません
でも
本当にこれから先の僕たちが生きていく上
で大事なものということを
人はカメラ時間だけでは
の中も6という地域というか
本当に気持ち良さ心地好さ
そういうことということにきちんと目を
受けて生きていくっていうこともは僕たち
時は大事になってくるかもしれ
持ってこれから先も
人の心に
引くようなそういうモノづくりを
100年200年続けているそういう
場所にありつであるなと思っています